Speaker 1: You know, we haven't spoken to for a
while our other Cancun caller, it's Bitdefender,
Bitdefender welcome.
Speaker 5:
Hey, David, how are you?
Speaker 1:
I'm fine. Excellent. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: I was listening, enjoying your Monday
train show about critical race theory, and there
was a point in the show in which you mentioned
how angry and how mad people got to these rallies
and events. I do believe there's some element of
heightened anger. You know, Republicans
seem more prone to outrage in this sense
because of the culture war. But that's beside
the point. The question is. Given that anger and
stress usually have negative health consequences
and this is a bit of a random question,
do you think maybe in the future we will see, you
know, statistically significant enough differences
in health outcomes by political ideology?
Speaker 1: Well, we already might. What's
so there's a very interesting thing about
that, which is the red states on average
have worse health care systems and lower
life expectancy. It's already the case
now. There is a real question as to
whether within those states there's a
difference in life expectancy based on political
ideology. But like, for example, Mississippi,
which is one of the reddest states, has very bad
health care. And you know, Connecticut, which is
a very blue state, has very good health care. So
we already see that that the counterbalance is
I believe it's still true that conservatives
on average, have more kids than liberals.
So you could I mean, it's complicated
math, but you could have a situation where
the Republicans have lower life expectancy, but
they're reproducing more quickly and that allows
them to keep winning elections. It's it's
we need more data to answer the question,
but it's an interesting one.
Speaker 5: Well, I mean,
I don't know about influencing electoral outcomes.
Yeah. You know, the question is mostly, yeah, like
individual health outcomes on average,
given the externalities of stress and,
you know, heightened negative emotion. Right?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, it's a question that we
just need data to answer, and it's data that
I don't have. The data we do have, though,
is that on average, life expectancy is longer
in blue states. And it would stand to reason
that if you extrapolated that out on average,
on average, you may well be right that leftists
have a slightly longer life expectancy than
right wingers by virtue of where they live,
not because of their ideology. You're asking
a more specific question, but but I think
it's a fascinating one. I don't know the answer.
Speaker 5: You know, it's one of those questions
that popped into your mind because you, you know,
you know you, you are a busy person, you live
stress on a daily basis, I guess. I suppose you
can tell that it does take a toll on your health.
Hmm. I can't imagine what it would
be to live in a world in which,
you know most of the Republican beliefs are. Well,
it's certainly true for them, you know? Yeah.
Anyway, that was my question. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: Hey, how are you? It's been years
since I've been to Cancun. How
are things there right now?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, the city keeps growing
big. Urban problems keep happening, keep popping
up. This is a city that was originally designed
for two hundred and fifty thousand people,
and we're breaking one point one
million, I think. Well, you know,
there's there's issues related to that. A lot,
a lot of wealth inequality between the planned
part of the city and the new parts for, you know,
various different reasons related to governments
Speaker 1: as someone who lives there. Do you
do you ever go to the hotel zone or do you do
locals never go to that area? Oh, I work at the
hotel zone. Oh, you work there? OK? All right.
Well, how about for people who are who
live there and don't work in the hotel
zone? Do they ever go to the hotel zone?
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah. So think of it like
you live in New York, I think. Think of it
like the the the nicer part of town that it's
not downtown, you know, it's like we're
the very high end restaurants are.
It's we're usually very affluent. People will just
usually just live, you know, like they will eat,
work and sleep in the hotel zone. God,
you know, incidences and whatnot. But
yeah, and you will see a big wealth
difference here between the people that
live here and the people that work.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. Got it.
All right. Well, I appreciate the call.
Great to hear from you again. Thank you,